hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play Ock so
dad one of the yeah I love this game so
much it's so charming and I played a lot
of charming games in my time it's gonna
be lady connect well just wanted to do
this Samba for you before we get started
okay so yeah that's lovely my wife why
don't you go take them over there and
I'll go off to the ticket both okay so I
just gotta get through the line ever so
gently Oh God
or I could just yeah let's do this way
excuse me pardon me I just need it
excuse me I need excuse me I need excuse
me sir
sir I need excuse me
do you need this do you need this sir
sir to you okay I'm just gonna put that
over there and I'm just gonna wait in
line like a normal human being you
didn't see anything over there no I'm
next I'm next
there's my coupang thank you very much
sir I'll take my ticket now and be on my
way
puns like that get you murdered sir
something smells fishy you always say
that
or no how do I keep out of their line of
sight they're looking right at me
Oh give me why are you booing me I just
knocked over something do you do normal
humans they can knock over things okay
can I get up here I couldn't even get up
the soda City so I highly doubt that
I'll be able to get up here oh god shut
up with the puns you're all really I
want it do you just wrap your legs
around every pole you see sir mr.
octopus perfectly normal normal to be a
little kid you all right I'm just in the
habit of beating little kids in the back
of the head everywhere I go yeah why
come on I do not want to grope this
shark can could you please come on come
on there we go all right here you go I
got the ticket lady can you just sorry
ma'am I ain't you a bid on your leg
there happens all the time okay oh that
was a clever joke did you get that one
this son made a very clever joke and I'm
gonna go in the bathroom here just
because it's here and I have a suspicion
that something important is in here yeah
do not trust for you toilet paper can I
have this what do I do with this put it
in the toilet that would make sense
what's that up there
can I do that no okay never mind I don't
think I'm supposed to be in here I
thought maybe there was gonna be a
secret do you need some do you need some
toilet paper sir I'm here to help as a
normal human being I will toss you this
or not goodbye leaving perfectly normal
you wouldn't be afraid of what you see
if the camera will just cooperate thank
you for your contribution do the normal
human are you going get back here yeah
really why is there a rain forest in an
aquarium this is all fully suspect I
wait there's a rain forest in the
aquarium in Cincinnati never mind
excuse me normal I'm normal normal sorry
I'm normal so normal and normal humans
are huge I really don't know where I'm
coming guys I'm just kind of exploring
around and that's what you do in an
aquarium you just go around till you're
bored I think
there we go entering the deep ocean home
to many strange and mysterious creature
[Music]
Stacy honey
Stacy honey Stacy honey I'm doing good
doing good doing good okay
what's a shake light I'm sorry kitty oh
man this aquarium is kind of awesome I
have to say no I just got this little
shake light Kitty it's like a shake
weight but not really as erotic cuz that
would be widow kid get up kid oh my
did my leg could you get off please but
please kitty
could you back up like two steps thank
you thank you very much kitty I love you
cuz I'm your loving caring dad shaky
shaky shaky shaky there we go alright
[Music]
really
right totally not because you're half
octopi octopus how do I get around him
camera here take it take it the best way
to go was oh god I was oh mister what
are you what are you doing here woo
shut up kid I got it all under control I
just need to do something here where do
I need it what are these they're like oh
I see there's buttons over here okay
because it's gonna eat you up little
kitty let's go Teddy can you get the
light in here thank you
this goes oh god why am i doing this why
am i the maintenance guy for all this
husky
alright that was one
move your arms please thank you there we
go oh no no no no that's not what I
meant to do okay I'm in a little bit of
a pickle here if you could oh my God my
legs why why guess where are my legs
oh my god Oh legs I'm you don't see but
I'm doing this it's like not
[Music]
okay thank you for doing that that's
really appreciated I really am thankful
for everything that you've done to help
me in this endeavor over here all right
why can't I move this why can't I move
this I see the three why can't I move
this oh I get it
Oh Oh it tired there I'm not gonna go
get it screw that noise to the other eye
okay got it okay witness the amazingly
cuddly snuggle fish a stuffed snuggle
fish toy makes a killer gift oh okay no
I'm pretty sure he's mean ravenous ugly
you're damn right I mean you would know
kid huh nice kid good one there but I
make great breakfast just cuz there's
ink all over it does not mean that it's
bad yeah there we go huh you're welcome
well now you can
now you can thank you kid you're such a
darling little kid I love you with all
my heart and soul I don't even know
ballet dance skills don't fail me now
thank you whoo all right shut up kid
yeah thank you
I bet you weren't undulated his
undulated mean hi okay there we go yay
oh my god that was oh it's difficult
that was very very difficult
shut up kid yes yes absolutely
wait who said that what humans said that
what human voice said that I want to
know I want to know right now all right
let's see what's going on in the arcade
I'm guessing this is where my son is the
one I'm actually proud of okay let's
take a breather go into this imperfect
city Oh No
yes honey uh-huh
uh-huh do you mind if I dance while we
talk just a little bit of a Samba yeah
yeah oh I'm so sensitive to your
feelings yeah
are you sensitive to these feelings oh
yeah oh yeah okay pump it up okay you
like how I pump it baby you like how I
pump this fish okay so you weren't
impressed by my pump AJ how about this
present over here for you my lovely lady
[Music]
who's talking who is that who's that
mysterious voice you guys do hear that
right okay I need it how do I do this
huh like I pull little nut I don't have
much muscle mass here hey dingus damn it
what if I do both arms dirt with oh what
if I walk and pull ah come on I got it I
got it I got this baby I'm not gonna
fail you now come on pull pull pull
kick through the can-can while you pull
ah I can't get up there anaconda I'm
just not strong enough babes how about
this the fish toss perfectly normal
oh sorry about the [ __ ] throw okay oh
these are live piranhas what the hell's
going on in this place
okay come on come on No
well oh wait I was using the wrong
control no I wasn't it's up it's back
and forward fling no yes yeah that's
better
kinda okay I didn't even have a fish at
that point okay I wanted to grab that
one oh yeah this is going to a hole
fantastically I think I pulled that fish
out of my ass this might take a while oh
come on
ah oh come on
whoo they expect from me oh my god you
got to be kidding me
oh you gotta be kidding me oh you gotta
be kidding me
oh god not again oh okay good that went
down thank you so much for being nice
and cooperative
oh I never want to ever ever ever to
ever ever ever ever ever ever here's
your damn prize
okay but you wouldn't go to the hospital
yet somehow no I'll explain in the next
episode so anyway oh my god I'm all out
of time for this one so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]